How do you control rumors and
gossip within an organization?
That's pretty easy. You just, you
just talked about being, you know,
getting out there for the truth and your
propaganda arm to outside your company.
It's no different inside your company.
You've got to make sure
that people [inaudible] I,
it's interesting that when you were,
we work with leaders sometimes you
see people that are like, well,
I don't want to share those
with my people. You know,
cause I don't know what they might think.
Like they're,
they're thinking something that
may be totally not true. They're,
they're not just sitting
there not thinking anything
because you're not sharing
it with them. They're coming
up to their own conclusions,
which may be completely false or
opposite. But like we say in the, in the,
in the navy all the time,
you know, perception is
reality. That becomes reality.
So you've gotta,
you gotta you can defeat the gossip
and rumors by actually just sharing the
truth. Be Open with
people and uh, and, and,
and be in first out there with a
message so people get an understanding.
And even when horrible, bad things go
wrong, extreme ownership, right? If,
if you take ownership for that and
say, Hey, listen, this happened.
Here's what we're doing to fix it. Here's
what we're doing to turn things around.
Um, it, it's kind of people,
people are not going to lose respect
for you and the organization.
They're actually going to gain
respect for you as a result.
Something we talk about all the time.
So don't be afraid to do that again,
just get the message out there and, and,
and be transparent and talk to folks.
If you don't tell people what's going on,
they're going to make up their
own ideas of what's going on.
And the thing that I have to,
I have to,
we have to, we have to take this
just a little bit further, right,
just a little bit further because
we talk about transparency, right?
And that word gets thrown
around all the time. And uh,
of the idea that you're just going to
you that the idea that you're just going
to tell everyone exactly what's going
on and that sounds great. And it's like,
Hey, I'm a fully transparent leader
and I'm gonna tell everyone's going on.
But there's times where you
actually don't want to do that.
There's times where you have to maneuver
and you have to be tactful and some of
the things that you might tell someone
actually is not the right thing to do.
Now I'm, I'm, I, I'm
not saying we're, we're,
we're going to be
dishonest with our people.
I'm not saying that and I'm saying
that transparency is a great thing,
but I mean, just on a personal
level, if laughs, laughs, uh,
working for me and he's not doing it,
he's doing something horrible is the
best way to go about that to fully true.
Full transparency is [inaudible]
you're doing horrible at this.
Is that the best way to do it in front
of the entire team in front of the right
is that, is that it's full transparency,
right? Hey, I'm fully transparent. Okay,
everyone welcome to the
meeting today by the way.
I just wanted to point out that life
mrs numbers again and he's a loser.
That might be what I'm thinking.
That's fully transparent. Hey guys,
I knew love lists too, right? Just being
transparent. Laughs and laughs a loser.
He missed his numbers again.
And you know what I'm actually thinking
about firing him just in case anyone was
wondering. So that's not going to
wait to close the business Friday.
Did I do a good job? Right? So, so
let's not get carried away, right?
You know, is the smart way. This smart
ways to maneuver the smart way is to say,
okay, lace not doing what he, what
he wants to, what he should be doing.
If I go and accuse him of failing, what's
his reaction going to be? How's it?
So what I do instead, instead I
go, I want to take ownership of it.
And so instead I say,
hey leaf, you know, hey,
come to conquer my office. I want to
talk to you about a couple things.
So he comes to my office or
not in a public place and
now it's, hey leaf. Hey Man,
I noticed that you, you know, you, you,
you missed your numbers and I'm thinking
that maybe I'm not giving you the kind
of support that you need to,
to get where you need to be.
Is there anything that else that you
need from me so that you can win again
inside? Sure. I'm thinking Lafe you
pathetic loser. You missed your name.